bonsoir galets bencheikh merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce soir en direct sur
rt france en accordant sept
cette interview aujourd'hui al jazira
une chaîne qui est proche des frères
musulmans
emmanuel macron s'est adressé aux médias
le plus suivi dans ce monde musulman
diffusé en arabe mais aussi en turc
le message at il était audible selon
vous je l'espère espérant le en tout cas
le président de la république à
rectifier si j'ose dire à déminer c'est
ce que nous n'avons cessé de serre
depuis quelques jours pour expliquer
deux choses
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne le
premier point c'était la notion de
l'islam est en crise et j'avais beau
expliquer qu'il ne s'agit pas de la
spiritualité scénic ou de ses préceptes
de pardon de réconciliation d'élévation
spirituelle de fraternité mais c'étaient
les sociétés musulmanes de par le monde
qui se trouve être véritablement crise
il suffit de voir la violence les
conflits les dictatures le despotisme
l'ignorance et ses pesanteurs sociales
robert le développement et le progrès de
ces sociétés dont il ya une véritable
crise
le second point c'était la phrase nous
ne renoncerons pas au aux caricatures
aux caricatures au pluriel
il ne s'agissait nullement sans vouloir
être le porte parole de la présidence de
la république française
mais dans l'esprit de ceux qui ne sent
pas de mauvaise foi il s'agit des
caricatures comme une tradition
française une tradition séculaire
maintenant c'est précisément ce qui a
mis aussi le loup en sorte qu'une
certaine partie en tout cas du monde
arabo-musulman en ébullition eux ne
veulent pas qu'on caricature le prophète
oui il y à un télescopage de deux
principes fondamentaux le sacré
pour les arabo musulmans pour les
croyants musulmans où l'on ne veut pas
que leur propre from prophète soit
tourné en dérision soit brocardé
caricature est tout simplement et
l'autre principe de la nation française
qui est la liberté d'expression à un
moment ou un autre il faut que nous
trouvions un terrain d'entente notamment
pour les musulmans de france pour dire
que le principe de liberté d'expression
comme un corollaire des libertés
fondamentales et la liberté de
conscience et la liberté d'opinion ne
doit pas être négocié le reste c'est en
appelant à la halle à l'intelligence a
une bonne lecture de la temporalité
celle qui sert à faire de maintenant et
a fortiori avec les attentats odieux
quelle que soit la cause aussi noble
soit elle pour les uns ou les autres
cela ne justifie nullement le massacre
des innocents
cela n'autorise en aucun cas d'aucune
manière
ce déchaînement de violence emmanuel
macron à 10 et section ses propos ont
été déformés en tout cas apprécié ces
deux discours vous pensez pas que recep
tayyip erdogan premier ministre du
pakistan est elle est très bien compris
ses propos pourtant ils ont aussi incité
les habitants à descendre dans la rue
il me semble que lorsqu'on est chef
d'état
il y a un discours de diplomatie de
sagesse de retenue on ne traite pas son
homologue de deux fous de
relevant de la psychiatrie et de je ne
sais trop quel autre propos au niveau
aussi de l'état pakistanais
il a dû y avoir quelques manipulations
de cet état de fait pour des
considérations de politique intérieure
et les appels au boycott des produits
français nous constatons pour l'instant
que c'est une réaction qui est à la
marge
c'est un entretien selon les et qui a
été enregistrée pour réparer en tout cas
ces contrevérités selon l'elysée et
réexpliqué les fondamentaux de la
république du modèle républicain
français ce que vous pensez que ce
modèle peut être compris par des
musulmans au pakistan ou ailleurs je ne
suis pas sûr il ya il y aurait deux
modèles en concurrence dans le monde
occidental donc le modèle anglo saxon
qui fait juxtaposer des communautés
parfois livre en s'ignorant et puis le
modèle républicain qui se veut lui aussi
universaliste
en tout cas et qui s'adresse si je puis
dire à des citoyens pris in abstracto
individuellement ce modèle là n'est pas
compris par certaines sociétés
musulmanes illusion dans des contrées
lointaines par rapport à la france
bien que ce soit et non parce que nous
vivons une ère de mondialisation à
charge cette fois ci pour la république
d'être fidèle à ses idéaux à ses valeurs
et à ses principes et je répète toujours
depuis quelques temps que nous sortirons
nous sortirons de la crise en quatre
temps il ya d'abord le temps des
ripostes sécuritaire et des forces de
l'ordre
bien entendu et heureusement qu'elles
parviennent à déjouer les attentats
lorsqu'elle ne parviennent pas c'est un
succès je mettrai le montre guillemets
des dés
criminel et 10 assists et cet islamisme
mortifère qui triomphe momentanément en
tout cas il ya une deuxième riposte qui
est celle du contre-discours qui
auraient dû y qui est élaboré et qu'il
faut encore le marteler et le faire
savoir pour expurger de la psyché et des
esprits de ces jeunes gens ignares
fanatisés et donc puiser ce
contre-discours de la tradition
religieuse islamique mais aussi de des
lumières des lumières j'parle de
l'héritage de la hausse kerong troisième
réaction elle est peut-être à moyen et
long terme ce sont les chantiers de
l'éducation de l'instruction de
l'acquisition du savoir de la culture de
l'humanisme et quatrième chantier c'est
celui effectivement delà de la
république la république doit nourrir et
instruire tous ses enfants
je ne fais que paraphraser la légende
d'honoré daumier pour l'un caricaturiste
mais je parle de lui comme le peintre
qui a dessiné peint l'allégorie de la
république là là on parle de la france
mais comment expliquer la liberté
d'expression c'est ce qu'a voulu faire
en tout cas à travers cette interview
emmanuel macron comment expliquer cette
liberté d'expression à des millions de
gens qui n'ont jamais entendu parler
finalement eh bien il faut de la
propédeutique de la pédagogie et
expliquer qu' il vaut mieux avoir cette
liberté d'expression qui pour celui
qu'ils exercent sans responsabilité à
blesser autrui que de ne pas l'avoir et
et avoir une propagande d'avoir des
journalistes qui croupissent dans les
geôles où à voir en tout cas il ne
propagande des pas s'il ya lieu à
choisir c'est autant avoir cette liberté
d'expression avec tout ce qu'elle peut
comporter parfois de dérapage que de ne
pas en avoir du tout et subir le diktat
merci beaucoup galets bencheikh d'avoir
répondu
ce soir à nos questions en direct sur rt
france